WAIS in the past fortnight report cards
on Australian maths and science students
have shown that they are either
stagnating or going backwards compared
with kids overseas the worrying result
has left governments wondering what went
wrong any parent can see that the
teacher is often the most important
element and our next guest is a perfect
example
Eddie Wu is the head of mathematics at
cherrybrook High School in Sydney he's
won the New South Wales premiers prize
for innovation in maths
he's also something of a YouTube fanatic
where many of his lessons get tens of
thousands of views let's have a look
according to the quadratic formula like
the quadratic formula has baked into it
says right
it has certs like it's part of the
formula you have to say minus B plus
minus the square root of you don't say
the square root of then you won't get
the quadratic form it won't get the
answers well thanks for coming in it's a
pleasure to be here head so were you
surprised by these results why are
Australian students struggling in
science and maths the peasant end
results that have come out recently
I didn't view them is particularly
surprising partly because we've seen a
trend over many years and we know that
there are lots of areas in mathematics
and science learning in particular that
we Australia have to learn from so I
wasn't particularly surprised I do think
it identified a lot of areas that we
need to work on so does it identify
areas of inequity in the system
advantaged kids versus disadvantaged
kids in different schools public and
private for example I think it's always
been the case that based on you know the
kind of experience you've had going all
the way through school and that's
obviously going to have a huge impact on
your achievement and we know that in
students in a year 8 class there's going
to be a huge range of a judgment from
the most struggling kid to the highest
achiever sometimes that gap can be up to
five years in terms of just academic
scores so we've always identified that
and that picture is always complex but
you know as a comprehensive school
teacher our role there's always take
every single student no matter where
they're at and to bring them forward so
what about the
quality of the teachers as well a lot of
people seem to agree that that is always
important obviously are we attracting
the best people into the profession at
the moment the quality the teacher is
one of the defining factors of a
classroom and it's hard to attract
people particularly in science and
mathematics I remember from when I was
going through school people with those
areas of expertise and the ability to
communicate which is so important for a
teacher there are lots of areas in us
outside of Education where there are
enormous opportunities very lucrative
and high status opportunities so
therefore it is difficult and challenge
that we need to work on to attract those
people into so what about you what was
your approach when you were going
through I mean clearly you're very smart
and had a lot of options and you have
decided to be a teacher to educate
children what led you to that decision
and what was also the reaction from
others around you when you did it the
two biggest factors that contributed to
me going into teaching were firstly I
had some incredible teachers going
through school and through them I had a
first-hand experience of the amazing
impact a teacher can make it's quite
astonishing how much time that you spend
with these teachers every day and the
kind of influence that they can have as
mentors toward you I experienced that
every day through my schooling and so I
thought wow there's an enormous
opportunity for there for people like me
to have a positive influence on the next
generation but secondly I had the
opportunity myself to I help other
people learn through extracurricular
activities at school leading in cadets
or as pre fixed peer support leaders the
Christian group and I just realized that
I love seeing people have that light
bulb aha sort of snap a moment where
they understood something they never did
before gain a new skill and I love that
did some people say to you you want to
be a teacher why why would you want to
be a teacher in a public school I think
a lot of people thought I was joking at
first because it sort of maybe was a bit
of a phase that I was going to go
through and there was there was some
shock because you know with the skills
that are important to a mathematician or
a scientist and being able to relate
well with people there are a lot of
different places that I could use that
but for me you know the purpose in going
to work making sure that I wasn't just
pushing paper around and this
every day at a desk that I got to me in
front of real people all the time that
was so attractive to me I couldn't say
no all right so explain to me I'm trying
to throw myself back to high school and
maths obviously wasn't one of my strong
points how do you make a kid interested
in learning mathematics
I think mathematics is interesting it's
a bit like music if you get to
experience the music that you love you
you can't have tear yourself away from
it but certainly music can be taught in
a way which is which is dry and cerebral
and disinterest in to anyone in
mathematics I feel this similar so I
find that helping students understand
okay why is this important
how's this used in the real world and
where does it appear in all kinds of
surprising ways helping students make
those connections is one of the most
important ways of helping them engage
and also just being interested myself I
think it's really important to take an
attitude of openness and excitement into
the classroom because students often
can't help but come along with that and
do they come along with it do you notice
something general if you have to say how
many how many students in your class
really love learning math I think to be
sure you'd have to ask them but one of
the things that I love most is to walk
into a classroom to greet them with a
would advance on my step as I enter for
the first lesson of the day and then
just to watch their eyes as a beginning
teacher I remember having to have
copious notes in front of you to know
what exactly I was going to explain and
as I grew and sort of was able to move
away from that I just loved to put my
eyes on students and say okay are you
with me are you understanding do I need
to slow down clarify and I can see that
moment in their eyes when suddenly it
they wired ameliorate and they realize
oh no I'm with you sir and an idea
clicks for them so back to the original
point about Australia's poor performance
in this area you as a teacher what will
you do or can you do to try and turn
that around and on a more broad level is
it even possible I definitely think it's
possible I've I've banked my hopeful in
the fact that it's possible and that's
what I'm putting my fear into every day
I'd say it's probably two big things
that I personally am doing in the
classroom
number one it's helping students see
that becoming going into education
taking some of our really elite students
people who really could do anything and
helping them see actually being in a
school is an incredible privilege and
opportunity helping them understand that
from an early stage is really important
and resourcing them and helping them
have everything at their fingertips that
they need to learn is always a challenge
but it's much more possible now than
ever before so the resources that I put
on the internet or to my students online
all those kinds of things making sure
that students can access them wherever
they are and anytime is really vital and
secondly contributing to the wider
teaching profession helping other
teachers who at the moment we're going
through a huge phase shift in terms of
new teachers coming in an enormous
amount of experience and insight leaving
just through retirement and all that
kind of thing and making sure that the
next generation of teachers is well
equipped and trained and has a support
network those are the kinds of things
that I'm doing the classroom well I kind
of wish I had a math teacher like you
when I was coming through high school
but thank you very much for your time
today it's been a pleasure